i admire neo the world ends with you for
its youthful attitude through eccentric
personalities and character designs
and it's so cheesy it's good vibe it
brings back how i felt all those years
ago with its predecessor
but that's also because while a sequel
that can be enjoyed on its own
its adherence to the original story of
the world ends with you brought me back
to another time
which might leave you lost if it passed
you by still
neo tuiwi has its share of attractions
like a standout action rpg combat system
that evolves into an exciting rush of
flashy spells filling up the screen
and while you might roll your eyes at
the cast of characters quirks in the
beginning
they'll grow on you like good friends
who are annoying at first the same can
be said about its soundtrack
songs that are odd upon first listen
become bops that get stuck in your head
[Music]
this is also a story heavy rpg with
intriguing twists and turns
however in its shallow riddle filled
objectives
and narrative wheel spinning
neo-twee-wee drags its feet for a bit
too long and too often before reaching
its payoff
now the setup is that the reapers game
is back a parallel dimension of real
world japan
characters trapped in it have been
posthumously invited to play a game of
ambiguous rules and objectives
for another chance at life but rules are
meant to be broken and parameters are
meant to be manipulated
so much so that you eventually disregard
its logic and just embrace the cool
nonsense
used to bend the fate of the characters
and the setting of shibuya itself
main protagonist rindo and his friends
fret and nagi all teenagers who
consistently rack their brains to
overcome the reaper's game's seemingly
impossible odds
they drive the desperate fight for
survival and supporting characters
whether they're friend or foe
make the core ensemble all the more
stronger while rindo is your avatar and
the level-headed empath
most of the supporting characters fill
in archetypes with confidence and their
own personal touch
which is also a testament to the great
performances by the voice cast
we've got this in the
[Music]
not bag you're just doing my job
characters are at the heart of neo-tuiwi
from their striking fashion sense
to their overstated idiosyncrasies it's
how you come to understand them
and they are what makes this game
memorable there are some notable misses
and unlikable characters but the wide
cast and the freedom of expression
neotiwie affords these personalities
make it easy to find who you identify
with and it's one of the strongest hooks
here
i definitely can't get into spoilers but
those who love the original tui
including myself
are treated to some hype moments through
important story connections and sweet
callbacks
a few aspects of this do come across as
ham fisted
but i also can't deny the jolt of
nostalgia that made the experience all
the more enjoyable
ultimately that leaves those who never
engaged with the original twee-wee
out of the loop nyotiwi tries to
accommodate by throwing in vague
references to what happened in the first
game
so neo-tuiwi will hit differently for
different folks
as for the storytelling neo-tuiwi takes
a long time to get the ball rolling
and sometimes drags its feet even when
things start to really heat up
it's not that the exposition is bad it's
actually where a ton of the charm comes
from
letting characters express themselves
and imprint their mannerisms in your
mind
it's just that there's so much of it and
it often feels like filler
and dialogue for the sake of dialogue
there is a lot to work through and not
all of it is particularly fascinating
it hurts its momentum by dragging you
through wild goose chases
funneling you from point to point for a
chunk of dialogue to move the story just
a step
forward and you're frequently asked to
solve riddles or investigate anomaly
which can sometimes be an interesting
brand exercise
but these moments frequently feel like
busy work rather than actually engaging
with the game's world
neo-tweewy is backloaded with some of
its best moments
but runs the risk of losing your
interest before it really gets spicy or
starts to pay off
it's also worth noting that most of the
game's story is told through character
portraits and panels
perhaps
exactly the game's wonderful art style
complements the approach
but the over-reliance on character
stills takes away from feeling present
in a bustling city like shibuya and that
things are actually happening in those
streets
it's a shame too because shibuya is
vibrant and the game's few cutscenes are
stunning
unfortunately in several story critical
moments you have to use quite a bit of
your imagination to visualize what's
happening
instead of actually seeing it unfold
combat picks up some of that slack
though
the chaos of the action-packed battles
is a visual treat especially as things
ramp up when extra party members join
the fight and thankfully it's a blast to
play too
you're done
so far
the foundation of combat are pins which
are equippable spells and attacks that
get mapped to a specific button
for a certain character depending on the
attack type you have melee range
charge damage over time and area of
effect abilities all of which can be
fired off simultaneously
or strategically used to string together
combos with good timing
doing so is rewarded in boosting your
groove meter which then lets you cast a
powerful
super-like ability to further pound your
enemies
you're constantly earning new pins
throughout the game giving you new ways
to engage in combat
and rethink what's most effective for
your party once you start building up a
collection of pins
devising effective combos and reading
the patterns of the various enemy types
neo-tweewy's gameplay really shines it
becomes absolute chaos when you start
stacking and juggling multiple attacks
yet remains fast paced and satisfying
what's more is that combat difficulty
can be fine-tuned at any moment in your
journey
neo twee-wee features the basic easy
normal and hard
or extra hard if you unlock it but also
lets you slide the party's level down in
increments
to further tweak the way you're
challenged it's also a means for
adjusting how you earn rewards like new
pins and experience points
in the overworld you can choose when you
engage with enemies and you can stack
encounters before initiating them you
could also just worry about the battles
necessary to advance a story if you want
neo-tuiwi is designed to accommodate
various play styles in creative ways
shibuya as your overworld is one of the
joys of neo-tuiwi as well
shopping for new gear and ordering food
to boost your stats in the different
districts
is a nice way to connect to the city and
build up your party
side quests while fairly basic in design
represent the lives of the people who
fill the streets
these help you unlock some in-game perks
and a few of these have neat little
stories to boot
lastly one of the most significant
pieces in creating the distinct
atmosphere
is the oddball yet lovable soundtrack
with a complete disregard for consistent
music genre you'll hear
grungy punk or full-on hardcore tunes
one minute then some catchy j-pop and
j-rock style bops
before going into up-tempo synthwave
[Music]
and overall it's so good music was
paramount to the first game's identity
and neo-tuiwi brings the heat again it's
a big way the game doubles down on its
attitude
and you can't help but admire that
despite my gripes with the ways nyotuiwi
almost stunts my enthusiasm for it
i'm glad it exists i can live with the
lulls along the way for its memorable
moments
and i can still wish it did more with
storytelling while loving its
personalities
sense of style and connections to the
original it's largely made for those
with a fondness for the first game
which becomes increasingly apparent as
the story goes on so your mileage may
vary
but the world of tui is a unique one
that offers a chance to feel
young wild and free and it's packaged as
a frenetic rpg that can be cheesy as
hell
in both its serious and lighthearted
moments but after embracing that it's a
journey worth considering